le bien-être animal fait aujourd'hui
partie des préoccupations de bien des
consommateurs avant d'acheter on
s'informe on veut savoir dans quelles
conditions les animaux ont été élevés
par exemple c'est d'ailleurs la prise de
conscience des consommateurs qui est à
l'origine de l'adoption des poulaillers
où les poules sont en liberté
mais si ces poulaillers sont un plus
pour les poules ce n'est pas exactement
le cas pour les travailleurs
[Musique]
pour répondre aux préoccupations du
public et à la nouvelle réglementation
en matière de bien-être animal
les producteurs de du canada ont
commencé à convertir leur poulailler
d'ici 2036 ils auront abandonné les
cages conventionnelles pour des systèmes
de logement alternatifs déjà le quart
des poules pondeuses sont élevés dans
des cages enrichi avec des perchoirs et
des pondoirs l'épaule en près de deux
fois plus d'espacé que dans les cages
conventionnelles
un autre système d'eau blanc cordes la
superficie dont dispose la volaille
l'élevage en liberté les poules ont
aussi accès à des pondoirs et des
perchoirs mais de plus elles ont de la
litière au sol pour prendre des bains de
poussière mais il ya un hic
un ami l'a peut-être le bien-être de
l'animal ou d'un côté on a comme
augmenter les émissions au niveau de
l'art et l'environnement est réduit de
qualité de l'air à l'intérieur du
bâtiment qui pourrait peut-être avoir un
impact sur la santé des travailleurs
stéphane goux debout est chercheur à
l'institut de recherche et de
développement en agroenvironnement irda
il s'intéresse à la qualité de l'air
dans les élevages de poules en liberté
depuis 2013 dans une première étude
il a remarqué une dégradation de la
qualité de l'air dans les systèmes sans
cage presser d'adopter ces nouvelles
installations
les producteurs de voulu connaître les
effets de ces logements sur leur santé
est-ce que la dégradation la qualité de
l'air est assez important pour amener
des problèmes de santé
c'est là le début de l'histoire dans ces
élevages en liberté les travailleurs
sont en contact plus direct avec lippi
quand avait augmenté la liberté des
animaux ça pu amener détonations humain
ne peut plus important ça peut être un
travail au niveau peut-être de retourner
et la litière ou drame a rossé les yeux
au sol je peux pas les laisser là en
photo mais monnet des rameaux ses excès
succès la mène un peu plus interventions
et à vérifier un peu plus et il pleut
plus de respect c'est le coup de bec
agressif de blessure en fait plus
attentifs
dans ses nouvelles installations
les travailleurs respire de poussière
qui flotte dans l'air du coup l'allié
des poussières qui peuvent affaiblir les
capacités pulmonaires
ce sont les petites particules qui sont
les plus dangereuses elles peuvent se
poser en profondeur dans les poumons et
même se retrouver dans la circulation
sanguine
or jusqu'ici peu d'études porte sur la
santé des travailleurs dans les systèmes
de poules en liberté
le laboratoire de caroline duchesne basé
à l'institut universitaire de
cardiologie et de pneumologie de québec
est pionnier dans ce secteur
son équipe collabore avec stéphane godin
aujourd'hui l'étudiante magali wayne
saint germain prend des échantillons
d'air dans une chambre expérimental à
l'aide de ces trois instruments
le premier permet de connaître la
grosseur et la concentration des
poussières dans le bâtiment
les deux autres détecte les bio aérosols
qui flottent parmi les poussières et qui
se dépose sur le filtre
magali wayne extrait ensuite les micro
organismes en laboratoire afin de les
identifier bactéries moisissures virus
et allergènes même inactifs les bio
aérosols sont dangereux pour avoir un
effet sur la santé respiratoire
les vieux russell n'ont pas
nécessairement besoin d'être des
organismes vivants donc ça peut être des
micro organismes qui sont morts des
débris de micro organismes
à ce moment là c'est vraiment leur effet
de stimulation du système immunitaire ou
d'inflammation potentiel inflammatoire
qui le peuvent causer des problèmes liés
aux déboires au sol qui sont des agents
infectieux des bactéries des virus qui
peuvent éventuellement effectué au
stylisme ça fait partie aussi des
risques associés au bio aérosols une
exposition prolongée sur le port du
masque peut entraîner des troubles de
santé respiratoire dans le milieu
agricole on recommande le port d'un
masque n95 profil très 95 % des
particules de certaines tailles le
cependant des problèmes au niveau des
éleveurs de poules pondeuses c'est la
quantité de poussière la constitution
peut devenir un frein à l'utilisation de
protections respiratoires parce qu'il ya
tellement tu sert à filtrer que l'on
veut bloquer les agents biologiques mais
aussi on fait face à de grandes
entreprises comme le match qu'à ses
limites
stéphane godbout veut réduire la
dispersion des poussières à la source
il teste une technique de vaporisation
d'huile végétale sur la litière au sol
ici c'est de l'huile de canola mais elle
avait amassé attaqué à l'émission
poussière donc c'est comme un peu un
aspect un peu de colère qui fait que les
fonctions restent au sol et s'envole
pour avec le but de piqué d'huile comme
une fois par jour où selon une certaine
prise aux logiques on pourrait décider
permet de réduire de beaucoup les
émissions de poussières
ça peut être fait maintenant quand les
pauvres sont peu mettront sur la litière
ou la nuit
on pourra appliquer un peu d'huile cela
permettrait beaucoup d'améliorer les
conditions de dollars pour le
travailleur principalement
[Musique]
l'huile est mélangée avec une substance
acide ce qui diminue le ph de la litière
avec ce mélange stéphane godbout
s'attaque à un autre défi réduire les
émissions d'ammoniac
car dans un élevage de poules en liberté
les émissions sont grandes
beaucoup plus grande que dans les cages
conventionnelles en batterie n'est
donnée travaux qu'on a fait on avait
comparé en batterie avec les cages
enrichi et les voyeurs et ça peut avoir
d'un facteur 4 à 10 fois plus élevé
envoya reversus en batterie l'odeur est
poignante l'ammoniac put hérité les yeux
le nez et la gorge toux difficultés
respiratoires et aux pressions à la
poitrine
les symptômes sont nombreux et aggravée
par l'effort physique
cette ammoniac provient de la
décomposition des fientes de poule la
grande quantité d'émissions vient de la
gestion de la litière dans les élevages
en liberté et 6 assists alors quand ils
dorment la nuit une portion qui récupère
et son décor way qu'elles sont sur le
plancher en bois mais une portion des
gens qui se retrouvent là dans la
litière dans les anciens systèmes c'est
tout resserré quasiment immédiatement en
tout temps
même si lui l'a signifié agit sur le ph
les émissions d'ammoniac dépendent aussi
de l'humidité
stéphane godbout cristaux donc
l'application de biocharbon le du
charbon est appliquée dans un premier
temps pour réduire l'humidité parce
qu'il absorbe l'humidité dans le cas ici
précis qui nous intéresse on l'a aussi
traiter à l'acide pour moi tease en ph
et en même temps modifie le péage la
litière et de et d'un jouet sur deux
paramètres importants qui l'humidité et
le ph
une autre technique réduit aussi
l'humidité le plancher chauffant l'achat
d'or du s'hydratent la litière au sol
dont carizza l'humidité
on rédige en ammoniac de beaucoup l'hôte
à face sur monde trop sec bien plus de
coucher avec année abus et le combiné
ici on fait comme jouer sur tout les
paramètres qui devrait permettre de
réduire l ammoniac de façon importante
je mets ces nouvelles techniques ne
doivent pas nuire au bien être animal
l'équipe du chercheur vérifie donc
régulièrement l'état de santé de leur
poule
une fois l'expérience terminée stéphane
godbout pourra offrir aux producteurs 2
de paul en liberté les meilleures
techniques au meilleur prix les
techniques en de développer y en a des
très efficace qu'on regarde mais le coo
d'application la faisabilité technique
reste toujours un peu des montres et
puis le coût de production
il faut pas trop qui augmente on
comprend ça c'est pour ceux que dalle le
projet qui s'en vient on va c'est de
voir si on est capable d'avoir une
technique peu trop coûteuse face et
d'applications qui donne pas trop de
travail ou plus de travail aux
producteurs au québec entre 2016 et 2018
plusieurs producteurs ont installé des
systèmes sans cage 16% des poules sont
élevés en liberté
mais aujourd'hui la tendance est plutôt
vers les cages enrichit les poules on
dénie et des pondoirs et en absence de
litière de fientes au sol la qualité de
l'air est meilleure pour les
travailleurs le problème c'est que
peut-être que le fait que ce soit à
pline cajou écrit encore un peu de
contention c'est le mauvais inspecteurs
perception des gens au moins une bonne
perception de ce modèle au canada en
2010 8 14% des eux proviennent de cages
enrichi mais 14% viennent aussi
d'élevage en liberté où les travailleurs
sont exposés aux poussières au bio
aérosols et aux émissions d'ammoniac
si la population désire toujours aller
de l'avant vers ce procédé là avec cette
technique leur faut trouver un moyen de
réduire cet impact négatif sur
l'environnement
c'est très important puis c'est ce qu'on
travaille à vouloir améliorer cet aspect
là pour ans les systèmes envoya rouen
liberté drama plus respectueuse autant
la santé des travailleurs que
d'environnement
[Musique]